I had a couple requests on reviewing
certain things, so I'm gonna do a few.
I just picked a few examples that I'll
talk about, but if in the meantime you
think of anything else you want to ask,
then ask at any point, okay?
So first, here's kind of a famous example
that I wanted to go through anyway,
which is good review of geometric
distribution and expectations.
Then we will talk more about
the universality of the uniform,
since that's the number one request, okay.
But first, let's do a problem
called the coupon collector.
I think a couple of the sections
did this problem or
something similar, but
not all of them definitely.
This is a really good example.
It happens to be very
useful in a lot of cases.
I think of it as the toy collector
problem cuz I don't collect coupons.
Well, I don't really collect toys either.
But I'd rather collect toys than coupons.
The problem is that you have a certain
number of different types of toys and
you want to collect a full set.
And it's one of these
Happy Meal type of things,
where you buy a Happy Meal at McDonald's
or whatever, and you get a random toy, and
you want the full set, right?
That's the problem.
The problem is, on average, how long will
it take you to collect the full set, okay?
So we have a certain number of toys,
let's say, n toy types.
I say type just because, to distinguish
between the individual toys,
you might get seven of the same toy,
right, but I mean,
seven of the same type, but
seven physical objects.
So there are n types and
we'll assume that they're equally likely.
Now, in practice they probably will make
one really hard to find so that then
people go berserk, going on eBay and stuff
trying to track down the one hard one, but
we'll assume right now
they're equally likely.
Problem gets very,
very messy if they're not equally likely.
Like, really, really tedious,
long calculations, you'd go on for pages.
So it's certainly not something
you would need to worry about for
an exam in this course because
the problems that you'll have to deal
with should have very short,
nice solutions.
And it gets really nasty if
the probabilities are unequal.
But in this case it
works out really nicely.
So the question is find the expected
time to collect a full set, where
time is just measured discretely in terms
of how many toys you need to buy, right?
Expected time, i.e., number of toys,
Until you have a complete set.
And if you think of breaking up
this random variable into smaller
random variables, then it's easy
to think about how to do this.
So if we call this T, for time and
T for toys, we want to know the,
T is the number of toys that we
need to collect to get a full set.
Let's think of just breaking
down T into components.
So it's T1+T2+ blah blah
blah, +Tn where T1,
Equals time until first new toy.
By new,
I mean a toy that we didn't already have.
Well, that's actually equal to 1,
cuz the first one you get,
that's your first toy, and you didn't
already have it, obviously, okay?
So T1 is actually just a constant,
always equal to 1.
Now T2,
after you've collected your first toy,
if you're unlucky the second toy
is the same as the first toy.
But most of the time you get something
new on the second try, okay?
So T2 is the additional time
until your second new toy.
So, new just means one you didn't already
collect earlier in the process, so
additional time until second new toy.
And then T3 is same thing
until the third and so on.
So additional time after the second.
That is, collect, collect, collect till
you get your second toy, collect, collect,
collect till you get the third, and
keep going like that until
you have all of them.
So all the way up to Tn, okay?
Then notice that T1 is just equal to 1,
but T2, let's think about T2.
So there are n different toy types and
we have 1 out of the n, so there's an n
minus 1 over n chance that the next
one is gonna be something new, right?
That, so we'd consider that a success.
So the success probability
is n minus 1 over n.
On the other hand, with probability 1
over n, we get a failure in the sense of
collecting a toy we already had and
then it's the same problem again.
So therefore T2- 1 is geometric with
probability of success n -1 over n.
The minus 1 is just because of
the convention about the geometric,
that we're taking the convention
that the geometric starts at 0.
But of course, you need at least one more
new toy, so I'm subtracting off that 1.
And in general, Tj-1
is gonna be geometric.
So Tj, we're trying to get the jth toy,
right?
That means that we already have
collected j minus 1 toys, so
it's going to be n minus the number we've
already collected, which is j minus 1.
So they're all geometrics.
Then we can immediately
write down the answer.
In this case,
these Ts are independent, but
linearity would hold even
if these were dependent.
Here they're independent because, right,
it's just like how long does it
take to get your second new toy,
but has nothing to do with telling
you the additional time, right.
But even if they were not independent,
it would still be true
that E(T) equals the sum
E(T1) + E (T2) + E of Tn.
And just to simplify that,
write out what that is.
So that's E(T) equals,
so E(T1) is just one.
E(T2), well we talked about
the fact that if you have
a geometric starting at 1
then the mean is 1 over P,
cuz that's Q over P plus 1,
because we're adding back the 1.
So the next one is just gonna be
the reciprocal of this which is
n over n minus 1.
And then the next one is
gonna be n over n minus 2,
and so on.
And then for the last term, that means
that we have n- 1 out of the n types.
Then our probability of success
is only 1 over n, right?
So for the last one, it's n.
Let's just write this as n over 1.
Then we can factor out n.
So this is really just n times, and
I'll reverse the order of terms just to
make it look nicer, it's n times one-half.
1 plus one-half plus one-third,
plus blah, blah, blah, plus 1 over n.
So that's called the n harmonic sum.
That looks like the harmonic series.
This is approximately n log n for large n.
That's just a useful fact about the
harmonic series that we can approximate
it as logarithmic.
But, in general for
a midterm and homework and
stuff, you should give exact answers
unless you're asked for an approximation.
So this would be the exact answer, but
this would be a handy approximation for
large N.
So we just used linearity and
geometrics here.
Sounds like it could have been a hard
problem, but you break it up into
pieces like that, use linearity, and
then it becomes an easy problem.
Okay, so let's talk a little more about
the universality stuff, and
there's always questions about.
So I just wanna draw a little picture and
do a quick example to show more
about what's going on with that.
So first here's a picture.
So we're talking in the continuous case.
So we have an x and F of x.
Just imagine drawing a CDF and
remember CDFs,
you know, they have to be increasing and
right continuous but for universality,
we're assuming that it's strictly
increasing and it's continuous.
So let's draw some kind of CDF,
maybe it looks like that.
And either it hits one and
then it would stay one forever, or
it just asymptotically approaches one.
Either way is fine.
But just to have like a picture in mind
of what's universality really saying.
What it says is, for
example, what if we chose
a random, this is lower case x,
this is just the x-axis.
But what if we chose a point
on the x-axis randomly.
So the question is basically,
let X be distributed according to F.
So X is the random variable.
F is this curve, this CDF.
And the claim is that when you plug X,
this is one-half of the universality.
Remember, we talked about two
parts which are equivalent.
So just talked about
one of them right now.
We said that if we plug X into
its own CDF, we'll get a uniform.
So I just wanna explain using
this picture, why is that true?
I think the easiest way to think of it is
just to make it a little bit more concrete
and pick a certain number here.
Let's say let's pick a number
on the vertical, so here's 1.
And maybe it hits 1, and
then it would stay at 1 forever.
Now let's pick some other
number on the vertical axis.
Let's say, here is one-third,
I just picked a y value of one-third.
And suppose that I ask the question,
let's call this point here x sub zero.
So, x0 is the point such that
F of x0 equals one-third.
That's the, you know,
just inverse of a function.
So, in other words, I'm just saying,
I'm just making up, for
some reason it looks really abstract
at first, but I found that if I
make up a number like one-third
it's easier to see what's going on.
So you could have chosen any number
between 0 and 1, but I picked one-third.
So I assume that F of x0 equals 1/3.
Now I want to know what's the probability
that F of X, that's a random variable.
Cuz we're plugging this random
variable into its own CDF.
We wanna know what's the probability that
this is less than or equal to 1/3, where.
So the interpretation of this F of X is,
we first pick a random value on the x-axis
according to this distribution.
This distribution is telling us how
do we select the random x value, and
then we compute the corresponding
y value which is F of x.
So that's how we compute F of X.
But notice that that's true exactly, so
I'm picking a random point here,
somewhere on this x axis I'm saying,
when is it true that the y value is
less than or equal to one-third?
Well, that's the same thing as
saying that the x value has to be
between here and here.
Because if x were to the right and
I go up, here it's bigger than a third.
And I said less than or
equal to one-third.
That's the exact same thing as saying
X is less than or equal to this x0,
but by definition of the CDF,
that's F of x0 equals 1/3.
And there was nothing special about
one-third here, you could do this for
whatever number you want between 0 and 1.
That's the uniform distribution.
The uniform distribution is saying that
probability is proportional to length.
And for the uniform 0,1 probability is
length within that interval 0 to 1.
So that's what we just verified.
That one-third became one-third.
So all this is saying is that the claim is
that F of X is uniform between 0 and 1.
And if you do the same calculation
with any number here instead of
1/3 any number between 0 and
1, same thing holds.
So that's what it's saying geometrically.
We are just relating random
points on the x axis to figuring
a random value vertically between 0 and 1.
And as a quick example of
how you might use that.
Suppose you wanted to simulate
from a logistics distribution.
We haven't defined
logistics distribution yet.
But I'll just tell you
what it is right now.
The logistic distribution,
which is another important
distribution in statistics.
That it's used in what's called logistic
regression for example which is very,
very widely used method in economics and
statistics and elsewhere.
It's based on the logistic distribution
which has the following CDF,
F of x equals e to the x
over 1 plus e to the x.
This is for all real x.
For practice with CDFs you can
verify that this is a valid CDF.
There's three properties it's continuous,
increasing, and so on.
You should check for
yourself that this function I wrote
down does have the properties of a CDF.
So that's a valid CDF but
that doesn't tell us how we could ever
simulate random variables
that have that CDF.
And if we want to do that,
an easy way to do it would be,
let U be uniform zero one,
which is easy to simulate, and
then consider just doing f inverse of u.
So if you set this thing equal to u and
then this is u in terms of x but
solve for x in terms of u just
by doing the inverse just a little
bit of algebra to get the inverse.
What you'll get is this function
log of u over 1 minus u.
So that's just the inverse evaluated at u.
Just do the algebra, compute the inverse
of this and that's what you'll get.
So that will be interpreted as the log of
the odds basically, if you think of this.
If u were just a probability between 0 and
1 that would be the log of the odds.
But in this case,
u is a random variable, so
we plugged it into its inverse CDF,
and then that would be logistic.
So if you just computed this thing,
then you would have a random draw
from the logistic distribution.
Now if you wanted, you can check that
that's true just by taking this thing, and
just compute directly its CDF.
Use the definition of CDF and
you'll get this, but
it's easier to recognize that
that's really why it's working.
Okay, so are there more questions
that you've thought of since before?
I have a few more examples that I
thought of, and things to talk about.
But anyway, let me know if you
think of any other questions.
I wanna do something more
with symmetry and linearity,
so here's just a fun little
symmetry problem I made up.
So let X, Y, Z, this is just
good practice with linearity and
symmetry, and what does IID actually mean,
things like that.
So let's Let X, Y and
Z be IID, positive random variables.
And the problem is,
find the expected value of (X/X+Y+Z).
Okay, now, you can't do linearity
on a quotient, you can't just say
that this is E of the top over E of
the bottom, or anything like that.
That's not linearity, you can't do
things like that, linearity is for sums.
Okay, so at first it looks like kind
of a mysterious problem, maybe.
We haven't really dealt much with
quotients of random variables.
And I didn't give you any
explicit formula for the CDF or
the PDF, I didn't say if they
were discrete or continuous.
I just said they are IID positive random
variables, I only said they're positive
just so that we don't have to
worry about dividing by 0.
No other assumptions, so
this is very general, okay.
To solve this, we just need to
see the symmetry of the problem.
The symmetry is that we have
three IID random variables, okay.
And we took one of them divided
by the sum of all three of them.
But by symmetry, that has to be the same
as E of (Y over (X + Y + Z)), right?
Because I could have listed
these in a different order,
and it would have been the same problem,
right?
It's completely symmetrical
because they're IID,
so maybe I should have written Y+X+Z,
but that's the same thing.
Right, it doesn't matter what
order you add them in, so
that's the exact same thing by symmetry.
Similarly, that's the exact same
thing as E(Z over (X + Y + Z)).
So whatever this quantity is,
it doesn't matter which way we write it,
because they're IID.
I'm not saying X = Y, I'm just saying this
problem, if I'd asked you this problem.
That is the same structure
as this problem,
it has the same structure of this problem.
It must be the same thing by symmetry,
so these two steps are by symmetry.
Okay, well now,
I have these three different expectations,
and that makes me think of adding them and
using linearity, so
what if we added these three things?
So if we added them, they would be E(X
over (X + Y + Z)) + E(Y over (X + Y
+ Z)) + E(Z over (X + Y + Z)).
Oops, X over, sorry, this is Z over
X + Y + Z, and then use linearity.
By linearity, that's just E(((X
+ Y + Z) over (X + Y + Z)),
okay, now that's a very easy problem,
expected value of 1 is 1.
But on the other hand,
this is the same thing added three times.
So 3 times this thing is 1, so that tells
us that the thing we want is one-third.
It's basically immediate by symmetry and
linearity.
And I think intuitively, this seems
like a very kind of general thing,
like how did that always work?
But if you think about this,
that's a pretty intuitive answer,
that would have been a good guess.
If you had done this and
gotten like 4 as your answer,
you should immediately know
that that would be wrong.
Because the denominator is
a number between 0 and 1.
The denominator is bigger than
the numerator, I said they're positive, so
it has to be something between 0 and 1.
One/third makes sense because if I asked
you just intuitively, we have three
things, and how much would you guess
that one thing contributes to the total?
One out of three things,
you would guess one-third, so
it's just a pretty intuitive answer.
But that's not a proof,
and this is a proof, so
that's just an example of symmetry,
linearity, that stuff.
Another thing we should talk
a little more about is LOTUS,
cuz LOTUS is something that looks very,
very simple.
But students may make
mistakes a lot with it, so
here's a simple LOTUS
example that I made up.
So here's the problem,
The problem is, let U be uniform 0,1,
and let X equal U squared, and
let Y equal e to the X.
Is that what I want, yep, e to the X,
and the problem is to find the expected
value of Y, As an integral.
In general, on the midterm,
I'll be very clear about,
you might have a hard integral
that you wouldn't have to do.
I would say leave it as
an integral in that case.
Or if it's stated that you should
actually compute the thing.
So basically I'll say whether it should
be left as a sum or an integral, or
if it doesn't say,
leave it as an integral.
Then you should get an actual number,
and fully simplify everything.
Okay so in this case, suppose I said
find this as an integral, well,
it's clearly a LOTUS problem, and
there's two approaches you could take.
But a lot of students in previous
years have kind of mixed up
the different approaches.
And it's kinda for an interesting
reason that I wanted to tell you about.
So one approach would be to say E(Y),
so we want expected value of Y.
Well, that just looks like
an easy LOTUS problem,
right, so E(Y) equals,
LOTUS says we integrate.
We'll just change capital
X to lowercase x, so
we go e to the x,
times the PDF of x, f(x) dx.
And we need the limits of integrations for
x, so u is between 0 and
1 so x is also 0 to 1, cuz you're
squaring a number between 0 and 1.
And so you get that, so
I mean this is correct,
where this is the PDF of x.
I mean this is true but
this would not, you know,
this is not the full answer because
you haven't said what's f of x.
I haven't said what's f of x.
I mean, I said it's the PDF of x,
but what's the PDF of x?
So if I say write it as an integral,
it should be like an actual integral where
you're saying what you're integrating.
Here we just said that's the PDF,
what's the PDF?
Okay, so at this point you could find
the CDF of x and
then take the derivative and get the PDF.
That's similar to the problem that
you just had on the homework.
Slightly easier here.
You had the homework problem about
uniform between minus one and one, okay?
This is a little bit easier, cuz you
don't have to deal with negative numbers.
So you could find the CDF and
then find the PDF and plug that in.
And that would be perfectly valid but
that'll be more work versus
doing it the better way.
The better way is to think of it.
Y equals e to the x is a function of x,
but x in turn is a function of u.
So I could also write this as e to the u
squared and do the LOTUS this way.
So if I did it this way,
then I would just say it's the integral
zero to one e to the u squared du.
Because we know that the PDF of
u is just one on this integral.
So if I did it this way, I can write down
the answer in like one minute, right.
This way, then you have to
do a separate calculation.
Now, I mean, I'm saying better just for
writing down the integral immediately.
Not necessarily better for
solving the integral.
If we wanted to get a number then
that kind of looks like the Gaussian
integral again,
except without a minus there, okay.
But the problem just says
leave it as an integral,
then this I could just
write down instantly.
And here we have to first find the PDF.
Both of these are correct though, so
you get full credit either way as
long as if you did either of these as
long as you actually worked out explicitly
what the PDF is, that's perfectly fine.
Where you'd run into trouble though,
a lot of students had trouble and
this kind of thing.
But somehow like mixing and matching
with these two things, somehow I think
there's a mindset that just because we
define LOTUS and we called our random
variable x and we looked at functions
of x that some how it depends on x.
And then if we add another LOTUS problem
where I don't even mention X and
then there's gonna be a lot
of answers where x's appear.
Well, what's x, right?
So the important thing is the pattern
not what you call the variables.
So, okay, well anyway,
that's just some comments about lotus.
Other questions on anything?
Yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah.
>> How do you find the PDF?
Yeah, so let's do that as quick practice,
not only with PDFs but with CDFs.
Okay, so, first find the CDF.
So, the CDF is the problem that u squared
is less than or equal to some number x.
That's x, but
I'm trying to reduce it back to you.
So the CDF would be this.
And as I said, it's kinda similar
to your homework, but easier,
because here we don't have to
worry about negative numbers.
So just take the square
root of both sides.
That's just the square root
of x if x is between 0 and 1.
That's the CDF,
the derivative is the PDF is just gonna be
one-half x to the minus one-half,
again x is between 0 and 1.
So we get the CDF take the derivative and
get the PDF.
To get the CDF, all we have to really
do is understand what a CDF is and
then reduce it back to the uniform
which is something we understand.
Okay, other questions?
Okay, so I wanted to do a quick
example of a story type of proof,
just to review that a little bit.
[SOUND] This is a very simple one but,
But I think it's
interesting, Just as quick practice,
right?
So quick story practice,
if we let x be binomial (n,p) and
the problem is find
the distribution Of n- x.
Well, one way to do it this is
quick practice with PMFs would be,
n- x is discrete let's find its PMF.
Well, it's PMF is the probability
that n- x is some number k,
but let's just rewrite that as
the probability that x is n minus k.
Those are the same events now
we've reduced it back to x.
Probability that x = n- k,
that's just from the binomial PMF and
choose n minus k.
P to the n- k.
q, q = 1- p, again,
q to the k, right?
So that was easy, but
a nicer way to write that
would be n choose k,
q to the k, p to the n- k.
So that would be the PMF method.
Remember that n choose n- k, is n choose
k which you can prove easily by using
factorials or just by the story, picking
k is the same a picking n- k, okay.
But a simpler way,
not that this is difficult but
an even easier way to see
this is using the story,
we can immediately say that
n- x is binomial ( n,q).
Just by interchanging successes and
failures.
Okay, so the story is that x is the number
of successes in n, IID Bernoulli P trials.
So x is the number of successes then
obviously n- x is the number of failures.
Okay, but we said repeatedly that you're
gonna find success and failure however
you want as long as each trial is either
success or failure, but not both.
So if we redefine success
to be failure and
redefine failure to be success,
then that's immediate.
So, I'll just call that
swapping success and failure.
Because you define it however you want,
right?
So we could redefine it the other way
around and then that's immediate.
So, no calculation whatsoever,
just one line.
Just swap success and
failure and that's it.
So swap success and failure and
I hope that none of you have
to do that on the exam.
But I think it's good practice.
Now, [COUGH] okay.
So we haven't done any Poissons yet
today, so
there's a Poisson example that I think
that is also a good practice question.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah,
the question is whether on the midterm
there may be questions where you
can just write things down in one line,
and yeah.
There's a good chance that you'd
have to write something, right.
But there may be several things
where you just write one line or
one sentence of explanation
because you see the story or
the pattern or the structure like
one sentence of what's going on.
You know, like this.
I mean this would be,
I mean just writing this immediately
then it doesn't say how he got there.
By saying we're interswapping success and
failure, that's a sentence and
there's a good chance
of something like that.
Which would save you some time,
that that's part of the point.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Do you get extra credit for
writing, it's immediately obvious?
Don't waste time writing it
as is immediately obvious.
You've ought to conserve time,
time is precious.
Yeah, so let's do a Poisson problem.
So here's the problem.
Suppose that the number of,
this is just an example that I like,
suppose that the number of
emails that I get, in a time interval
Of length t, let's just say time t,
is distributed as Poisson of lambda t or
a lambda of some constant.
So we're thinking of lambda as a rate,
rate times time,
right, so if I get say 20 emails
per hour times the number
of hours then that would be
the expected number of emails.
Remember that this is lambda
t is both the mean and
the variance of this distribution, okay.
So it's a random variable because
in different intervals of length t,
I mean I may, I'm not always gonna get
exactly the same number of emails so
there's some distribution to it, okay.
Now the problem is find
the PDF of T which we
define as the time of
the first email like,
let's say right now it's time 0,
starting now what time
will my first email come?
So that's in continuous, right?
That's a continuous time problem, right?
Because the emails could arrive
at any time in continuous time
where as this is discrete because I'm
counting the number of emails, okay.
So this is kind of neat because
it just connecting discrete and
continuous and well,
let's see how to do it.
So find the PDF or the CDF, once we have
the CDF just take the derivative, so
I would normally say
find the distribution or
find the PDF or the CDF,
any of those would be fine.
So the CDF would be the probability
that T is less than or equal to t.
That's a little bit, remember, this is
general advice when finding probabilities,
you should think about is it
easier to find that probability or
find the compliment.
In this case,
if you think about it a little bit,
you'll see that it's easier
to find the compliment.
Let's find the probability
that T is greater than t,
little t, so that's just 1 minus the CDF
so if we have this, we know the CDF.
This is a little bit easier to think about
because if we imagine a time line here,
where here's time t.
And if we draw an x every
time we receive an email,
T > t means that the first email,
let's say it's there, so
that's time capital T,
is to the right of here, right?
That says from times 0 to t,
you have no email, right?
That's exactly what this says.
It says that in times 0 to t,
you have no new mail, right?
It's exactly equivalent.
Therefore, that's the exact same
thing as saying that the P(N).
(T>t) says that Nt = 0 where Nt = # of
emails in that time interval from 0 to 2.
So I'm defining Nt to be the number of
emails in this time interval, 0 to t, but
T greater than t says there are none,
right?
So it's the exact same thing.
And we assume that this is
Poisson lambda t, so this thing,
just using the Poisson PMF
is e to the minus lambda t,
lambda t to the 0, over 0 factorial.
Well, that's just e to the minus lambda t,
right, so
the CDF is 1 minus that,
1- e to the minus lambda t for
t greater than 0, and if we want
the PDF just take the derivative.
So you got lambda e to the minus lambda t,
okay, so that's connecting the Poisson,
counting number of emails to this is
called the exponential distribution,
again related to our homework problem, and
again we'll talk about
this distribution later.
You don't need to know
the exponential distribution yet, but
it will be reasonable to be able to
do a problem like this where we're
just using the Poisson which is discrete,
to get a PDF.
Well, lastly I just want
to remind you again,
be very careful of the difference between,
we sort of have three classes of objects.
We have our distributions,
the distribution is the blueprint for
creating a random variable,
that was our random house.
And then don't confuse the random
variable with a constant,
a constant would be a specific house,
the random variable is the random house,
the distribution,
the CFD is the blueprint.
And so mixing up those things causes a lot
of trouble, so be very careful about that.
All right, so good luck.